[Musica]
non vi nascondo adesso non può mozione
anche se sono contento di essere qui
oggi a raccontarvi qualcosa del mio
lavoro io faccio invito biologo e
spenderò ai prossimi minuti di questa
nostra chiacchierata che cercare di
screditare un po le frasi sono scritte
là sopra che identificano e il mio
lavoro risolve problemi che voi non
sapete di avere i modi che voi non
riuscite a comprendere che è una frase
sicuramente abbastanza simpatica ma che
è un po una sconfitta fra ricercatori
che vi vuole raccontare quello che con
passione fa tutti i giorni
io sono un microbiologo e in particolar
modo mi occupo dello studio dei batteri
che possono dare origine delle infezioni
nell'uomo siano infezioni più banali
come mal di gola infezioni più gravi
come la meningite batterica glielo
faccio principalmente studiando un
fenomeno particolare è quello della
resistenza agli antibiotici che è quel
fenomeno per il quale i batteri hanno la
capacità alcuni batteri di sopravvivere
moltiplicarsi anche in presenza del
farmaco antibiotico è quel fenomeno per
il quale quando è un'infezione urinaria
prendono antibiotico l'antibiotico meno
riesce ad uccidere il microrganismo che
mi infetta perché il localismo resiste e
o e di fatto non guarisco questo è un
fenomeno che fino a qualche tempo fa
veniva studiato con qualche lavoratore
di nicchia con qualche sottoscala di
qualche laboratorio di microbiologia
clinica marchio g c'è in qualche modo
esploso fra le mani e che ci ritroviamo
a livello globale
potete immaginarvi che quando sono stati
introdotti sul mercato ma non si va agli
antibiotici siamo a circa la metà del
secolo scorso
questa rappresentato una vera e propria
rivoluzione nell'ambito medico perché
quelle infezioni che fino al giorno
prima non erano curabili dal momento in
poi sono diventate facilmente trattabili
questo ha chiaramente portato una grande
ventata di ottimismo
nell'ambito nell'ambito medico e tanto
ottimismo tanto entusiasmo ha portato
che alcuni ricercatori si sono riuniti
di fama mondiale e nel 1966 fecero
questa previsione e consegnarono alla
rivista time dissero che entro l'anno i
due militari erano praticamente sicuri
che grazie ad antibiotici tutte le
malattie infettive sarebbero state in
qualche modo debellare
ecco probabilmente al timer una mora
lunga perché nell'anno 2000 pubblicarono
questa
certi ma ricordandosi di questa di
questa previsione la rivincita dei
batteri killer
stiamo perdendo la battaglia con tre
malattie infettive
purtroppo la risposta è sì e la
situazione è peggiore rispetto a quella
che veniva identificata in questo
articolo
all'inizio del 2000 stiamo perdendo
questa battaglia e le resistenze di
antibiotici sono ormai un fenomeno
globale che si ritrova il tutto il mondo
ma non attaccano le varie nazioni che
vari territori nello stesso modo
guardate questa speciale classifica di
quanto è frequente la resistenza agli
antibiotici nei vari paesi della
comunità europea che possiamo definire
un po allargata in questa classifica
le barre verdi più lunghe sono le barre
verdi e peggiore è la situazione
guardate dove siamo noi siamo al terzo
posto e siamo sul podio peggio di noi
fanno soltanto grecia e turchia
vuol dire che la resistenza agli
antibiotici è un fenomeno importante
globale che comprende tutto il mondo ma
tiene alcuni stati e purtroppo ci siamo
anche noi fra questi il problema è
particolarmente grave è particolarmente
importante e questo perché è grave è
grave perché gli antibiotici perché
chiaramente le infezioni che adesso che
oggi ci sembrano così facilmente
debellabili non lo saranno figure
saranno infezioni che torneranno ad
essere mortali
e poi perché l'antibiotico immaginatevi
e deve essere che può essere utilizzato
non soltanto percolare le infezioni ma
anche per prevenire le infezioni
questo significa anche interventi
chirurgici che noi consideriamo come
interventi di routine come un parto
cesareo oppure un'appendicectomia non
saranno gli ultimi ma torneranno ad
essere interventi al rischio divisa
perché non avremo più niente con cui
affrontare eventualmente le infezioni
che possono derivare vi sarà quella che
viene chiamata dal capo della world
health organisation il ritorno all'era
pre antibiotica e la fine della moderna
medicina così come noi la conosciamo
chiaramente questo fenomeno è così
importante che già sta facendo centinaia
di morti guardate circa 700 mila persone
si calcola che muoiono ogni anno a causa
dell'esistenza di antibiotici 3000
soltanto in italia e le previsioni
purtroppo sono ancora peggiori un report
del governo inglese ci dice che nel 2050
se non prenderemo delle iniziative
importanti per combattere la resistenza
ad antibiotici i morti ogni anno saranno
a 10 milioni l'antibiotico resistenza
sarà prima a causa di morte nel mondo
più del cancro dieci volte più degli
incidenti automobilistici e allora la
domanda a questo punto è perché siamo
finiti in questa situazione perché la
situazione ci è sfuggita di mano
il problema ovviamente è multifattoriale
non può essere in qualche modo
banalizzato però sicuramente c'è un
indiziato speciale che è quello del
soprano servizio dell'antibiotico
abbiamo considerato l'antibiotico come
qualcosa di scontato come qualcosa che
avevamo sempre a disposizione abbiamo
cominciato a utilizzarlo senza chiederci
quali potessero essere le conseguenze
e allora il primo colpevole il
sopravvento dell'antibiotico in ambito
della medicina umana guardate questi
dati sono dati americani due persone su
tre prendono un antibiotico per
l'infezione respiratoria senza di verne
che in realtà ha bisogno è la classica
la prescrizione medica perdonatemi il
termine un po a casaccio veneto è
scritto un antibiotico il paziente lo
prende ma magari a un'infezione virale
per la pole l'antibiotico non ha alcuna
efficacia l'antibiotico combatte batteri
ma non combatte i virus
però non c'è soltanto il medico che
prescrive magari il farmaco senza che ci
sia una vera necessità c'è qualcosa che
possiamo fare anche noi
vi faccio un esempio e vediamo se vi
riconoscete in questo esempio
voi avete un'infezione urinaria andate
dal vostro medico il medico che
prescrive giustamente un antibiotico poi
tornate a casa prendete la prima pillola
di antibiotico prendete la seconda e
siccome l'antibiotico quando funziona
effettivamente è veramente efficace dopo
la seconda somministrazione genere i
sintomi questo non doveva succedere
i sintomi sono completamente spariti
che cosa succede quando la
sintomatologia di sparisce c montana
tira quando la sintomatologia in qualche
modo di sparisce succede una cosa
particolare i sintomi
questo e l'antibiotico non resiste
grazie scusa quando vi siete presi la
seconda dose di antibiotico quello che
succede che la sintomatologia
generalmente sparisce che l'antibiotico
quando funziona effettivamente un'arma
molto importante ed efficace però che
cosa vi rimane vi rimane un po di
stanchezza un po di nausea un po di mal
di pancia vi rimangono quelli che sono
gli effetti collaterali dell'antibiotico
allora generalmente che cosa facciamo
smettiamo il trattamento antibiotico
prendiamo la nostra scala degli
antibiotici la mettiamo nell'armadietto
sopra dove teniamo tutte le medicine
salvo poi ricordarsi che questo parte
l'antibiotico c'è sempre quando abbiamo
qualche altro sintomo che ci fa pensare
ad avere un qualche infezione qualche
infezione batterica d'ora ci ricordiamo
che c'era quella scatola mezza
cominciata andiamo nel nostro armadietto
prendiamo questa scatola finiamo
l'antibiotico senza consultare prima il
medico o peggio ancora prendiamo
festanti biotico lo prestiamo al nostro
parente un nostro amico perché lo posso
utilizzare quando ritiene più opportuno
stiamo sopra utilizzando l'antibiotico
ci stiamo mangiando degli antibiotici
del quale non abbiamo bisogno che stiamo
utilizzando un antibiotico completamente
a caso è purtroppo il problema non è
soltanto legato alla medicina
all'utilizzo al suo fratellino
dell'antibiotico nella medicina umana
pensate che negli stati uniti il 70 per
cento degli antibiotici che vengono
prodotti vengono utilizzati per
l'allevamento per quale motivo perché
quando noi diamo gli antibiotici ai
nostri animali che alleviamo queste
diventano belli grassottelli belle di
robusti belli forti in pochissimo tempo
sono dei potentissimi fattori di
crescita e anche quando l'antibiotico
non può essere utilizzato come il
fattore di crescita come accade in
alcuni paesi ad esempio anche se da
pochi anni nella comunità europea
l'antibiotico può essere comunque
utilizzato negli allevamenti intensivi a
scopo preventivo
pensate che cosa accadesse mo di questi
fogli uno di questi maiali prende
un'infezione batterica in pochissimo
tempo la distribuisce a tutti gli
animali che sono dell'allevamento
intensivo
ecco perché nel pastore che viene dato
da mangiare a quest'animale per esempio
inserito un qualche antibiotico che
impedisce e questo perché questi e
infezioni possono in qualche modo
svilupparsi ma purtroppo non c'è
soltanto questo l'antibiotico viene
utilizzato nella pesce cultura per cui
viene liberato nelle nostre acque
l'antibiotico che utilizza la funzione
gli anticrittogamici antifungini
nell'agricoltura
che cosa significa tutto questo
significa che noi tutti i giorni stiamo
liberando tonnellate e tonnellate di
antibiotico nel nostro ecosistema nel
nostro ambiente e questo produce quella
che in termini tecnici viene chiamata
una pressione selettiva che uccide tutti
i batteri sensibili e lascia in vita
quelli resistenti
è per questo che ci troviamo con i
batteri resistenti anche nelle nostre
infezioni per cui sicuramente è arrivato
al momento in cui dobbiamo guardare
negli occhi quel ghiaccio negli occhi e
cominciare ad intervenire in maniera
molto importante dobbiamo certo studiare
per scoprire nuovi antibiotici ma
dobbiamo anche cercare di imparare a
utilizzare correttamente quelle già
abbiamo a disposizione per fare questo
dobbiamo studiare le vie di trasmissione
dell'antibiotico resistenza per cercare
di bloccarle dobbiamo migliorare quella
che aveva diagnostica per cercare di
essere più efficaci più rate nelle
nostre malattie infettive
però dobbiamo fare anche una crescita
culturale una crescita culturale che ci
deve portare a capire come va utilizzato
antibiotico dobbiamo smettere di
utilizzare un antibiotico negli
allevamenti intensivi
dobbiamo far crescere categoria medica
perché per scrivere antibiotici in
maniera più oculata
ma dobbiamo anche noi per ricordarci che
quando prendiamo un antibiotico
questo farmaco e non assumiamo non è un
qualcosa che effetto soltanto su di noi
e come può essere un farmaco che la
pressione ma in qualcosa che effetto
anche su tutti quelli che ci circondano
solo facendo questo salto culturale
potremmo qualche modo riuscire a mettere
in atto delle degli interventi nazionali
o anche internazionali che ci permettano
di limitare e di sconfiggere
l'antibiotico resistenza
vi ringrazio
[Musica]
grazie tommaso per le spicce che avevo
detto era un po inquietante quindi
l'antibiotico possiamo considerarlo come
un farmaco sociale addirittura ti volevo
chiedere una cosa di batteri ce ne sono
tanti no diverse specie di batteri hanno
la possibilità di passarsi le
informazioni sulla resistenza agli
antibiotici
certo così questo peggiorerebbe
ulteriormente la situazione
questo è un punto molto importante è uno
le spiegazioni per cui i batteri
riescono a diventare così facilmente
resistenti agli antibiotici batteri
hanno questa brutta abitudine di
scambiarsi frammenti di dna riescono a
farlo in maniera molto veloce e lo fanno
anche in quelle sono degli incubatori
naturali come può essere il nostro
intestino dove vivono decine di specie
diverse di batteri scambiandosi questa
informazione genetica riescono a
scambiarsi anche quella l'informazione
della resistenza agli antibiotici che
quindi non si diffonde soltanto ci siamo
in maniera verticale da cellula madre
accedo la figlia ma può anche
trasferirsi da batteri contemporanei
anche di specie diverse e questo rende
tutto molto più complicato
[Musica]